so the falcon and the winter soldier has
just finished or if you notice they
changed the name at the end to captain
america
in the winter soldier and there are
still plenty of unanswered questions
i've been covering every episode of the
series and was busy yesterday with
mortal kombat videos
too bad you will die so instead of doing
a breakdown i figured we'd get right
into the meat and potatoes with all the
show's unanswered questions
i've left timestamps below so you can
see all the topics i'll be covering
including contessa valentina allegra
defontaine that's a mouthful
the birth of us agent and the power
brokers big plans but before we begin
consider giving the video a like and
subscribe
it really helps the channel first up we
have val don't call me that
played by julia louise dreyfuss who we
first saw in episode 5
there's much more to her character in
the overall mcu
as i stated in my episode 5 breakdown
you don't just hire an
a-list actor for two scenes in a
mini-series her character will play a
much larger role and as i theorized
maybe
putting together a team that could turn
out to be the thunderbolts a group
consisting of reformed super villains
after all she does hand out these
business cards like she's recruiting and
used to be romantically involved with
nick fury
she also wears purple zemo's color
suggesting they may join forces at some
point
it was reported in vanity fair that
julia's character was set to make an
appearance in black widow
but since the film was pushed back it's
not entirely certain
if that will be cut or changed due to
the events of falcon and the winter
soldier
but one line she says that really stuck
out to me was this one
yeah well yeah things are about to get
weird valentina definitely knows a lot
more than she's leading on and
considering the ending of wanda vision
and
future mcu films like doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
and rumors that the next spider-man will
deal with the multiverse
things are definitely going to be
getting weird look for valentina
ushering in a new group of heroes or
perhaps
villains in future mcu editions next up
baron zemo one of the most beloved
mastermind villains in
all the mcu also known for his flawless
dancing
in episode 5 he was taken by the
wakandans to the maximum security prison
the raft but it's clear he still has
contact with the outside world his
butler oznik is seen holding the
detonator to a bomb that will kill the
remaining flag smasher leaders
zemo hates the flag smashers destroying
their super soldier serum
killing the man who made the serum and
calling them supremacists
having zemo in prison also leaves him
plenty of opportunity for more powerful
people to manipulate but the strongest
evidence that zemo will return is that
a he's still alive when bucky could have
killed him so they're keeping that
option open
and b he's just so damn popular in the
mcu as we'll find out with a lot of the
unanswered questions in this video
marvel is
leaving a lot of options open then
there's the question of what will happen
to john walker or as he's known now
u.s agent after being given an other
than honorable discharge the most severe
administrative discharge not requiring a
court martial
he's stripped of his captain america
title and all ranks in the military but
it now looks like he's working for
valentina and the fact he tries on his
new suit in the same room he was
stripped of his title
is telling it proves that valentina is
somehow connected with the government
why else would they have this scene here
after all she meets him in the halls of
a government building
no longer having to prove himself as
captain america wyatt is free to do what
he wants his heart seems to be in the
right place after saving the truck of
grc members near the end of the finale
but as we see with his temper and ticks
us agent seems like the guy who could
easily snap
look for him continuing his allegiance
with valentina as we learn more about
her plans
we then have the power broker who at the
end of the series
turned out to be surprise surprise
sharon carter she's given a full pardon
by the us government and the ability to
be reinstated to her old job
before going rogue to help steve rogers
this job was working with the cia but
the power broker has bigger
plans and the fact bucky and falcon
don't know she's the power broker means
that mcu isn't done with her just yet
when carly confronts sharon we get a
small glimpse at what's motivating her
to turn against the u.s
she wants vengeance towards those who
turn their back on her
and in the mid-credits scene she is on
the phone with an unknown conspirator
talking about how she'll now have access
to government secrets
prototypes and weapons but who is this
mystery person
whoever it is seems to be someone higher
up or more powerful than her i got the
feeling that she is working for this
person
valentina comes to mind zemo as well but
he's in jail and that's a bit risky
having a casual chat like this over the
phone
i think one of the craziest theories out
there is that she's talking to steve
rogers which leads me to the next
unanswered question where is steve the
last we saw him was at the end of end
game and no one seems to know where he
is
the running gag this season is that he's
living on the other side of the moon in
the original sin
comic storyline there is a space station
there where the elderly nick fury lives
and bucky eventually ends up taking over
fury's role
as the man on the wall which is the
person in charge of defending earth from
otherworldly threats
at any cost so there is a connection
between falcon in the winter soldier and
the moon
beyond those gags and with the potential
multiverse possibilities there's no
telling how cap may come back
if at all as of the writing of this
video kevin feige has said that chris
evans will not be returning to the mcu
but honestly and never say never in the
mcu we do however know there's going to
be a fourth captain america movie which
is currently in the works co-written by
malcolm spellman the creator showrunner
and head writer of falcon and the winter
soldier
nothing is known yet about this but it's
safe to assume it will start anthony
mackie
as the new captain america one person we
see very little of in the final episode
is joaquin torres
myself and many others theorized that he
would appear in the finale as the new
falcon but it seems marvel has left the
door
open too with sam taking up the mantle
as captain america this leaves the
possibility of someone stepping in
falcon shoes
and there's no one who's admired falcon
more than torres
in episode 5 sam leaves his broken
falcon suit with him
telling him to keep it so it's easy to
assume tours might reappear with this
fixed suit in either this new captain
america film
or another mcu property then there are
the flag smashers with the leaders
essentially all dead this still leaves
hundreds of thousands of their loyal
followers it's created a power vacuum of
sorts which someone could easily take
hold of
that is of course if sam's speech to the
grc members actually gets them to change
in his speech he asks the members if
they ever bothered to ask why a person
like carly
does what they do maybe if they
understand that they can change their
policies so attacks like this will never
happen
people returning from the blip has
obviously caused tremendous instability
throughout the world and how those in
power decide to hold on to it will
either result in a new antagonist taking
hold or the dismantling of the flag
smashers altogether but with the
symbolism of the mask alone on the
pavement combined with sam's speech
it's most likely we're done with the
flag smashers next up is the super
soldier serum
according to carly all the vials have
been destroyed and with the serum's
creator dr
nagel killed in episode 3 along with the
deaths of the soldiers who took the
serum
the only two people left who have super
soldier blood are john walker and isaiah
bradley i mean there is a flag smasher
who fell into the hudson that falcon has
asked to save the other end but it's not
confirmed if it's one of the super
soldier flag smashers
remember that isaiah bradley was tested
on for years by scientists to extract
this super soldier serum
so it's possible with john walker still
alive a similar thing could happen
i'd say we're done with the super
soldier serum storyline for now but i'll
keep it on my radar so we kind of figure
out what direction falcon's story is
going as he learns to take on the
responsibility of being captain america
but what about bucky he leaves his book
of amends with his therapist dr raynor
after telling his neighbor yori he
killed his son while he was the winter
soldier
all the names are crossed off he leaves
a note saying he
finished the book a notebook which used
to be steve's bucky's future is
completely open here he could team up
with falcon again
go back to wakanda or even be
manipulated by sharon in helping her out
the possibilities for him are
endless his character is pretty well
liked in the mcu so i wouldn't count on
this being the last we see him and last
but not least sam and sarah's shrimp
boat you think a guy who fought thanos
and brought down the flag smashers would
be able to get a bank loan to save his
family business well it's a pretty
jovial ending as they celebrate so i
think the business will be just fine
maybe with cap's new role he won't have
to worry about paying the bills
so those were my biggest unanswered
questions about the series what do you
think and what are your thoughts
make sure to like and subscribe and
leave a message below for more bad takes
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much